hey wassup guys is marcus around here
from mkbhd and welcome to another full
review video this is going to be the
hardware review of this um this sound
tech gm3 gooseneck desktop microphone by
Alta Edge now if you haven't already
watched my unboxing video this is going
to be a video response to the unboxing
video so if you want to go check that
out you can go ahead and see what's in
the box see my first impressions of it
but now that I've gotten to use it for a
little bit I've had a little bit
different impressions but yet you might
want to watch full videos just so you
can see what I think so here is the
microphone itself it is a gooseneck you
do have a tilt or a pivot one here and
one here so you do have two ways to a
tilt or pivot your microphone so to get
you know optimized to be closest to your
mouth or closest to your face when
you're speaking it is a really good
quality microphone I'll give you a brief
little hardware tour of it obviously
because it's such a great microphone but
what I want to get into is actually just
the overall build to this so I'm
actually going to bring the camera down
here and right now obviously I do not
have a tripod but this will have to do
at the bottom here is the the actual
base the base is really heavy actually
it's made of it feels like a metal but
I'm still not quite sure what the base
is made of but it's a very solid build
on the back we can see our microphone
connection so this is where it connects
if I go ahead and unplug this here it's
the it's a stereo microphone plug I do
have a little time to take this out but
it's a stereo microphone plug as you can
see there are three pins on the inside
so it's a very solid you know good build
cable you just go ahead and attach that
and it fits just fine so I actually have
this this cable here wired to go down go
down underneath
I guess and come up and plug into the
microphone part of my laptop which works
out very very well and I usually have a
microphone base right here for my
tutorials in front of the webcam of the
PC and the microphone right here so our
setup does work very nicely it is a nice
long cord you can see the exact length
of the cord in the description but it is
a pretty pretty big desktop microphone
and if it's sitting on my desk like this
I will take the cord and you know kind
of wrap it down and make sure it's
pretty much all the way out of sight and
then I will take the microphone itself
and put it on the edge of the desk and
use the actual the ability to tilt this
microphone which is so great and just
total tilt it into the position and it's
ready to go so um you can see I have a
little foam cover on it it does come
with two foam covers in the box so um it
does do a good job of preventing like
excess noise if you're doing a tutorial
and you're close to the microphone but I
think the real feature of the mic is the
quality of it so what I'm going to do is
switch the source from this digital
camera to the webcam of my PC and we'll
be able to hear exactly how good this
quality is and I'm still changing a
teeny bit with the settings so basically
I think I've got it down so let's go
ahead and switch sources here and you
can hear just how good the quality of
this microphone really is so let's go
okay guys I've just switched over from
the digital camera audio here this
terrible microphone or terrible camera
right here the microphone on this camera
is very very small it's obviously not
very good but you may or may not be able
to hear I hope you do that this the
quality of this microphone is really
really good I've been using this for the
past about three tutorials or so and I
mean it's been really impressive I've
gotten comments as far as that that that
microphone is really really good a lot
of people like it so I'm definitely
gonna be using this as opposed to the
built-in webcam microphone on my laptop
as this does obviously Trump that the
stereo quality is very good the little
foam piece on it definitely keeps the
sound nice and even no popping or
clicking or anything and it is a
unidirectional microphone so you're not
going to really have very much
background noise so if I do talk over
here notice how the sound got a lot a
lot different when I moved away from the
microphone
but as I'm talking like this it's just
really easy very very clear to
understand what I'm saying so I'm going
to give this microphone a generous nine
out of ten I have been nothing but
impressed with this microphone the only
thing is that the the gooseneck is just
a little bit too small if I mean right
now it's I think it's 16 inch yeah it's
a 16 inch adjustable neck because I'm
looking at the specs over here on this
monitor it's a 16 inch
adjust microphone and you can adjust it
pretty much as far as you need to but
just for my needs if it was just a
little bit more flexible possibly the
entire gooseneck I don't know but yeah I
give it a some 9 out of 10 this is the
highest rating I've given any hardware
so far so I definitely suggest you go
check it out the link is in the
description um this this is good stuff
it's it's right now I and a previous
recording of this review I I said that
this was the best microphone that you
can get the best quality microphone that
you can get for under under $100 so
definitely if you're looking into buying
a microphone for tutorials for vocals
for singing for anything like that this
is the microphone you want to check out
and that's basically it so thanks for
watching this microphone overall
hardware review I hope you enjoyed it a
lot more tutorials and ideas that I have
like I have a lot of tutorials to do and
I also got three packages today in the
mail for unboxings and also I have about
two more reviews to film for you guys so
obviously if you haven't subscribed
already you're gonna want to do that and
that's basically it so thanks for
watching this HD video um that's
basically it for you guys thanks for
watching peace